il valore di un uomo non si misura con i
traguardi raggiunti
ma sono con i sogni che lo tengono in
vita
se qualcuno di voi in questo momento mi
chiedesse cosa ci faccio qua fra queste
bellissime montagne a parlare di mare
Beh
francamente vi confesso che non so se
riuscirei a trovare le parole giuste per
rispondergli
Ma la vita è un viavai di trame treni
che vanno e vengono anche se ogni tanto
qualche
carrozza si ferma alla tua fermata
una fermata un po' inusuale in un posto
dove non ci sono le stazioni nei binari
né insegne
però questa volta ho deciso nonostante
io di trame treni ne abbia lasciati
parecchi
ho deciso di montare su questo tram e di
provare a vedere dove mi importa
ho passato una vita a guardare
distrattamente la trasparenza
poi
d'improvviso mi sono accorto che quella
trasparenza
ero io
pensate trasparenza Che parola strana
è una parola senza significato che non
anche etimologicamente non vuol dire
niente deriva dal latino trans più
inspiro guardo attraverso
Io quando guardo una persona attraverso
non guardo altro più la mia indifferenza
non vedo niente perché quel problema non
fa parte della mia vita delle mie
priorità della mia esistenza perché io
sono asettico facciamo un esempio
noi quando compriamo l'automobile la
assicuriamo in quanto L'assicurazione è
un fardello necessario che ci previene
da un sacco di grattacapi
non fosse obbligatoria non la faremo
perché dai diciamocelo chiaro noi Non
saremo mai la causa di un incidente gli
altri ci verranno addosso gli altri che
erano i problemi noi non siamo troppo
bravi troppo forti per creare dei
problemi
per la disabilità è la stessa cosa
Noi pensiamo di essere
lontani dal problema ma se ci pensiamo
con attenzione noi tutti siamo nati
disabili tutti quanti nessuno di noi
sapeva camminare nessuno di noi sapeva
parlare scrivere mangiare vestirsi
crescere e abbiamo avuto da subito
bisogno di un
ho una badante tutti Nessuno escluso e
questo pensiero ovviamente così ci
riporta ad un senso di leggerezza e di
compiacimento come eravamo come siamo
diventati
però i nostri volti si rabbuiano
pensando che un giorno
e questo toccherà tutti quanti se non
avremo la possibilità di prendere un
ascensore veloce che ci porti oltre
quelle montagne e dovremmo salire
lentamente le scale del Paradiso
avremo tutti quanti bisogna ancora una
volta di assistenza di qualcuno che ci
accompagni e che ci porti in giro
che ci Guidi
che ci cambi il pannolone
che ci faccia compagnia noi quando noi
probabilmente guarderemo nel vuoto
perché grazie alla chirurgia al
Progresso a tutto ciò che oggi la
scienza ci offre abbiamo la possibilità
di cambiare tutti i pezzi del nostro
corpo ma il cervello No il cervello ha
una vita propria e proprio in virtù del
benessere di tutto ciò e di tutta
l'accelerazione che noi viviamo
probabilmente invecchia e non riesce a
metabolizzare la nostra vita
Perché la vita è un viaggio circolare
si torna sempre nel punto da cui si
partiti
trasparenza Noi abbiamo deciso nel 2012
grazie
a un'illuminazione a un sogno quando
siamo partiti con una barca di una
persona che mi sta ascoltando in questo
momento per un viaggio di 76 giorni
lungo le coste italiane con un velista
cieco completamente cieco per combattere
una malattia che mi friggeva una delle
più brutte malattie
Lo spettro della depressione una
malattia occulta e pensiamo pensiamo
sempre che le malattie occulte quelle
nascoste sono molto più pericolose delle
malattie di Renée Perché una persona in
carrozzina la vedi una persona che
cammina male una persona che non ci
sente un cieco
Ma le persone depresse quelle che
nascondono il proprio dolore il proprio
malessere dietro un sorriso Quelle sono
veramente pericolose e imprevedibili e
rovinano lentamente la vita a se stessi
e quello a quelli che gli stanno a
fianco questo viaggio mi è servito quale
introspezione emotiva ma soprattutto mi
è servito ad accettare la mia disabilità
mi ha servito ad accettare la mia
debolezza e a chiedere aiuto noi in
questi anni con la nostra associazione
abbiamo portato in mare quasi 1.500 Anzi
oltre 1.500 persone abbiamo percorso
15 mila miglia pari quasi a 30.000 km
abbiamo due basi una base a Trieste Anzi
a Sistiana che fa riferimento a Trieste
Gorizia una a Lignano per Udine e
Pordenone abbiamo fatto convegni
congressi parlando di sport bullismo
disabilità che sono comunque legate e
abbiamo coniato un nuovo termine per
quella che tutti chiamano disabilità noi
le persone con disabilità per noi sono
diventate i protagonisti perché sono
protagonisti perché siamo andati ad
appiattire quella differenza che
solamente delle persone che hanno
dimenticato
lo spessore della trasparenza erano
incominciato a dare contorno e colore
alla disabilità riescono a fare
Io alla fine del primo viaggio
con queste parole voglio
ringraziare Ted che mi ha invitato a
questa a questo appuntamento io sono
quello che chiude un po' questa giornata
e devo dire francamente che
le pietanze di questa giornata sono
state meravigliose io come come dessert
Spero di essere all'altezza di questo e
vi dicevo proprio in virtù di quello che
è stato fatto di quello che vorremmo
fare Vorrei leggervi ciò che ho scritto
nel momento in cui tornando da quel
viaggio con Egidio il mio velista cieco
Ho scritto nel libro che riassume un po'
la nostra storia
il mare libera mentre orizzonti
ambizioni e scelte
il mare gratifica chi lo ama Lo rispetta
e lo conosce
il mare punisce chi lo tradisce e
sottovaluta il mare raccoglie tutto ciò
che la terra scarta perché il mare è
buono
vorrei rendere ed essere capace di farlo
ciò che la vita mi ha dato
vorrei dare agli accessibili oggi
protagonisti una parte almeno di tutto
ciò che per me è stato inaccessibile e
che oggi non noi più
vorrei insegnare se mi sarà concesso il
gioco delle maree la danza dei venti la
paura di temporali l'abbaglio dei lampi
la misura delle onde è una parte dei
segreti nascosti negli abissi vorrei che
in tanti potessero dedicare i loro
pensieri allo spazio del mare dove non
si costruiscono garrite ne sbare di
confine dove i carri armati non
galleggiano e le armi bagnate non
sparano più
vorrei che in tanti guardassero le Albe
e i tramonti dal mare e che quelli che
come Egidio il mio cieco non lo possono
fare ascoltassero le parole di quelli
che come me hanno avuto la fortuna di
raccontarle
vorrei ancora raccontare di accessibili
oggi protagonisti che hanno scoperto
sorrisi nuovi guardando il mondo da
altri orizzonti vorrei che in tanti
avessero avuto la fortuna che ho avuto
io di nascere morire
rinascere ancora e chissà quante volte
questo potrà ancora succedere
vorrei regalare ancora la magia della
vita vorrei amare ancora ed essere amato
vorrei vivere non con la paura della
morte ma con la paura di non avere
vissuto tutto questo negli anni è
diventata la nostra filosofia ed il
nostro mondo dove Ormai tutti sono
diversamente uguali
[Applauso]